Okay, guys. So welcome to video number 37.
We're going to continue now with our
timing appraisal as part of our overall
trade idea generation process. And we're
going to be looking at price action or
momentum indicators. So how does price
action actually fit in here? Well, in the
previous video, we looked at TA, technical
analysis and price action.
patterns, TA patterns that play out
frequently throughout history to judge
whether our timing on a trade idea is
either good, a green light, bad, a red
light, or indifferent, an amber light on
our traffic light system. And we also
mentioned in the previous video that if
you get to the technical analysis stage of
checking whether you have good timing or
not, so when you're looking at a technical
analysis, you're looking at a technical
analysis stage of checking whether you
have good timing or not.
looking to turn a trade idea into a
position. But if the timing didn't look
right, then of course, you can sit back
and wait by just keeping it on the watch
list. And this is also the case for price
action indicators. So we have to basically
use both technical analysis and price
action indicators together. But in
understanding how price action
fits in fits in fits in overall, we have
to get a bit more specific on time
horizons. So with technical analysis, we
seek to get the bigger picture. If you
recall from the previous video, we were
looking at TA patterns over periods of
weeks, months, and even years to put into
context, our one to three month time
horizon. With price action, we look over
for days and weeks to discover whether we
have momentum on our side when we're
entering into our time horizon of the 20
to 60 day trading days period. So
remember, technical analysis is the study
of patterns and formations. And price
action is the study of momentum. And in
the context of any time horizon, you have
to use TA and P
in conjunction with each other in order to
get the full picture and use them as
accurately as possible to fit the time
horizon of our process.
for this period.
that signals frequently occur.
in terms of working smart, in terms of
working smart, not hard. So first of all,
momentum indicator one, we're going to be
looking at the relative strength index,
RSI, on a 14 day and 20 day period.
Secondly, momentum indicator two, we're
going to be looking at simple moving
averages. And for us as traders and
portfolio managers operating in the 20 to
60 day time horizon, we're going to be
looking at simple moving averages, SMA,
and SMA,
of 20, 60, 120, and 250 trading days.
Next up, momentum indicator three,
we're going to be looking at exponential
moving averages,
so EMAs over the same time horizons,
20, 60, 120, and 250 trading days.
Momentum indicator four, we're going to be
looking at
moving average convergence divergence,
or what's more commonly known as, or
referred to as MACD.
We're going to briefly look at periods of
12, 26, and nine days
for our MACD parameters, but we're also
going to change that up
and look at it specifically for our own
time horizon
for 20, 60 days, and 10 days.
And then our final momentum indicator,
momentum indicator number five, we're
going to be looking at
Heiken-Ashi candlestick charts.
Okay, so let's start with momentum
indicator number one,
the RSI, the Relative Strength Index.
So what does this measure?
Well, it measures the speed and change of
price movements of an asset.
And it oscillates between a value of zero
and one hundred.
And in financial markets, there's
vernacular that's used with the RSI.
So when a stock has an RSI above 70, above
the 70 level, on the zero to 100 scale,
it's termed that the stock or the asset is
overbought.
And when it's below the value of 30 on
that scale of zero to 100,
it's termed as being oversold.
Now, just generally, when it comes to
stocks,
very strong price movements you're going
to find are usually associated
with very strong fundamentals and or both
panic and irrationality.
So this would be very, very strong
momentum.
So a very strong price move is basically
equal to strong momentum.
And the Relative Strength Index, the RSI,
is going to pick this up.
And when RSI reverses, it's argued that
momentum is coming out of the move.
However, as you're going to see with the
RSI calculation,
an asset can go up, for example, very
quickly.
So it has very strong momentum, but it can
continue going further up.
So further in the same direction, but just
at a slower pace,
which means the RSI can fall and a stock
price can keep going up.
So you have to be very, very careful in
terms of how you interpret the calculation
and interpret the vernacular that's
attached to the calculations of RSI.
So when it comes to RSI, just a very good
discipline will be to treat the terms,
the vernacular of overbought and oversold
in quotations,
with as much caution as we do when we look
at fundamentals.
And the market refers to stocks as both
cheap and expensive.
But there's no denying it.
Momentum is important because it can
basically confirm or deny our fundamental
findings
in our trade idea generation process.
So if we've done our fundamental work and
we come to the technical and price action
stage
where we're trying to figure out whether
our timing is good, bad, or indifferent,
we might actually be quite foolish here to
think that our idea is well-timed
if we're looking to perhaps enter a long
position
when the RSI is at what's termed as
overbought levels and falling,
or vice versa, if we are looking to put a
short on,
to enter a short position when the RSI is
what is termed oversold and rising.
So although the RSI calculation and the
vernacular is sometimes misinterpreted by
traders
or most certainly by retail traders, it's
not exactly unuseful.
It's actually useful, but we just have to
be aware of its drawbacks.
Now the calculation for RSI is pretty
straightforward.
So the RSI is just 100 minus 100 divided
by 1 plus relative strength.
Where relative strength, RS, is the
average of the days of up closes
divided by the average of days of down
closes.
Now the most common time horizon that
you're going to find out there in the
market
is 14 days for RSI.
And it's very likely that whatever
software you're using,
or even if you're using free software,
even on the internet,
it's very likely that the days that they
will default to will be 14.
This is the most common and most standard
time horizon used for RSI out there.
But you have to always ask yourself the
question,
what do these days represent?
Well, 14 days doesn't really represent
much
and doesn't represent much for us.
We are 20 to 60 day time horizon traders.
So we actually change this to a 20 day
period.
So we can highlight an example here,
a real world example of the differences
between 14 day and 20 day RSI.
So if we look at this stock, for example,
Newmont Mining Corp.
So Newmont Corp.
NEM.
We can chart this stock in 2021 and chart
the 14 day RSI and have a look at some
results.
And we've pinpointed four areas on the
chart where the RSI was briefly touching
the level of 70,
where the interpretation of technical
analysts would have been that NEM was
over.
And remember, this is a 14 day RSI.
If you look in the bottom left hand
corner, you'll see the RSI is calculated
as 14 days.
And what happened here on three occasions
when the RSI hit 70 or just briefly below
70,
very close to 70, where conditions would
have been interpreted as potentially
overbought by technical analysts.
We can see that, yes, the RSI did fall
after that on those occasions,
but the stock price consolidated, did go
slightly lower, but ultimately went
higher.
So what's happening here is that the RSI
is calculating that momentum, price
momentum is coming out of the stock.
But this is a good example that it doesn't
mean the stock can't go higher.
It just goes up at a slower pace.
And you can see here, for example, in the
chart, where the fourth time we witnessed
this in 2021,
this is when the stock was at around
73.74.
So the stock price, $73.74, and the RSI
was in the high 70s, almost at the 80
level.
For the fourth time in the year, price
momentum, the RSI was slowing down,
and then the RSI dropped below 70.
But you can see the stock price pretty
much stayed at the same level.
So the stock price didn't drop.
So this is a great example of a 14-day
RSI.
And that if you'd have come into this
stock at least the first three times with
a fundamental predisposition of bullish,
you may have been potentially buying the
stock in the first three times.
But let's say, for example, you came into
the stock with a fundamentally bearish
predisposition.
Well, first of all, if you understand what
we've discussed so far,
you would put less emphasis on 14 days, so
you would change this to 20 anyway.
But let's say you were looking at this 14
days with a fundamental bearish
predisposition.
You would recognize that, yes, the price
momentum is very positive.
But at the same time, if I go and short
the stock, it doesn't mean the stock can
fall.
It just means that the momentum of the
price move up slows down.
So your interpretation and understanding
of RSI is very important.
Now let's look at the 20-day RSI and we
get a different picture for exactly the
same stock.
The only time when we get a true signal of
RSI condition on the 20-day RSI
is that same period in May that we looked
at in the 14-day RSI.
So now imagine that you are coming into
this condition where you're looking at the
20-day RSI
and not the 14-day RSI, let's say in March
2021,
and you are coming into this with a
fundamentally bullish predisposition.
Well, you don't have what's termed as an
overbought signal.
So it's likely as you go through your TA
checklist that the RSI here on the 20-day
RSI
would be showing you positive price
momentum and agreeing with your
fundamental view.
What would have happened if you came to
this stock in March 2021 with a bearish
predisposition?
Well, it would have disagreed with your
fundamental view
and you probably would have stuck it on
the watch list and waited for a slowdown
in price momentum
and for the stock to reach an overbought
condition.
So if you'd have waited and held back for
a couple of months,
you would have got your genuine overbought
conditions in May 2021.
And then if we just fast forward a week
further from the same time horizon
that we looked at in the 14-day RSI,
you would see that the stock actually did
drop by a decent amount.
So when it comes to entry for us as 20- to
60-day time horizon traders,
yes, we much prefer to look at a 20-day
RSI rather than a 14-day RSI,
which is basically meaningless to us.
So whatever software you're using,
whether that's a free one or paid one,
you must try to change your RSI settings
from 14 days to 20.
Even then, you do have to still interpret
RSI properly.
It's a very bad habit of retail traders to
think that just because an RSI is above 70
and shows what is called overbought
conditions,
or it's below 30 and shows what is called
oversold conditions.
It's a very bad habit of retail traders to
think that this automatically means
a stock must be able to go down on
overbought conditions
and go up on oversold conditions.
That is just not the case.
Stock price momentum can slow down and RSI
can reverse and go back in the other
direction.
But it doesn't mean the stock has to.
The stock can continue in the same
direction or even just be flat.
But as long as you treat RSI properly and
understand it properly,
it's a good price action momentum
indicator to have on our price action
checklist
as we're doing our timing appraisal.
Now, next up, our second momentum
indicator on our price action checklist
is simple moving averages.
What does a moving average do?
Well, it confirms or denies whether price
momentum is slowing or rising in a stock
and whether momentum might be turning.
But you have to remember, similar to RSI,
simple moving averages, they are lagging
indicators
and should only be used to confirm or deny
stock moves.
How do we calculate it?
Well, let's go through an easy
calculational explanation here.
A simple moving average, SMA, is a stock's
average price over a given number of days.
So if we take the last 10 days of stock
price data from any stock,
let's say the last 10 days, the stock
closed at 6, then 5, then 6, then 7, then
9, 8, then 8, 10, 13, and then 16.
So if we have 10 days of stock price data,
well, we just work out the average, the
10-day moving average of that data is 8.8.
So if we look at the 10-day moving
average, we look at the last three points
of data and we work out the average there.
So the three-day moving average from that
data is 13.
Now, if we plotted both a 10-day trailing
moving average and a three-day trailing
moving average on a stock chart,
in this instance, the three-day moving
average will be cutting the 10-day moving
average from below.
And this would be indicating positive
price momentum.
And of course, the reverse would hold true
as well.
If we worked out a shorter-term moving
average from a larger data set and the
average for the short-term moving average
was lower than the longer-term average,
at some point, that line on the chart will
have crossed the longer-term moving
average from above.
And this would indicate negative price
momentum.
Now, for us as 20-day to 60-day long-short
portfolio managers, our short-term moving
average,
so the short-term moving average that we
use, is 20 days.
So a 20-day simple moving average is just
the sum of the closing prices for the past
20 days,
the past 20 trading days, divided by 20
days.
And it's important to think of the
significance here of certain time
horizons.
So in trading, for whatever reason,
traders generally reference the 50-day,
100-day, and 200-day moving averages as
being significant.
But you have to ask yourself obvious
questions here.
What is the significance of 50 days?
What is the significance of 100 days and
even 200-day moving averages?
Well, from what we can see and what we can
tell, there is no actual significance of
those time horizons in the stock market.
Because when it comes to stocks, stock
market data, and even companies, in terms
of their reporting periods,
50 days, 100 days, and 200 days just
simply don't mean anything.
So typically, on average, there's 20
trading days in a trading month.
So a short-term simple moving average, we
use as 20 days.
So we have a one-month simple moving
average.
And then we also have 60 days, which is
significant for a couple of reasons for
long-short portfolio managers for our
medium-term simple moving average, which
is for three months.
Why?
Because, firstly, 60 days is equivalent to
three months of stock market data.
So we have our one-month and our
three-month simple moving average.
And secondly, 60 days is important in
terms of trading data because companies
themselves report on a quarterly basis.
So between quarterly earnings reports, on
average, we're going to have around 60
trading days.
We also look at half a year or two
quarters.
So we look at 120-day simple moving
averages.
And we also look at a full financial
calendar year.
So a calendar reporting period of one year
for a company, which is 250 or around 250
trading days.
So our 120-day simple moving average and
our 250-day simple moving average are, for
us, our long-term moving averages.
And taken together, 20, 60, 120, and 250
days, we have our short, medium-term, and
long-term simple moving averages for the
stock market.
Why?
Because these numbers actually mean
something, unlike 50, 100, and 200 days,
which don't mean anything.
So how does this look when we actually
amend our software from 50, 100, 200 days
to 20, 60, 120, and 250?
Well, here we have the S&P 500 cash index
displayed on the chart.
You can see we have price there, and we
also have our 20, 60, 120, and 250-day
simple moving averages charted as well.
And generally speaking, if you think of
our simple moving averages as short-term,
medium-term, and long-term,
a 20-day simple moving average, crossing a
60-day simple moving average, tends to
confirm or deny three-month views.
So for our time horizon, 20 to 60 days.
So if we apply this to the recent history
of this chart for the S&P 500 cash index,
and we look at May 2020, as the world was
coming out of the COVID sell-off,
and there was still a lot of chaos going
on,
you can see on the chart at the beginning
of May 2020,
the 20-day simple moving average was
crossing the 60-day simple moving average
from below,
and indicating to us strong
short-to-medium-term price movement.
Then if we fast forward to July 2020, we
get the 60-day simple moving average,
crossing the 120-day simple moving
average.
This happens almost right at the beginning
of July 2020,
and then very soon after, the 60-day SMA
crosses the 250-day from below.
And for us, as 20- to 60-day long short
portfolio managers,
when we see conditions like this in the
bigger picture on a chart,
a 60-day SMA crossing a 120 or 250 SMA
tends to confirm or deny six-month views.
Now, of course, we don't have six-month
holding periods for either longs or shorts
at all,
but if we pull up a chart in the bigger
picture and we see conditions like this
occurring in recent history
into the context of our fundamental
predisposition and we apply the traffic
light system,
and by default, at this stage, you should
know what your actions should be.
So, green light, trade.
Amber light, consider trading or half a
position or a partial position.
Red light, do not trade.
So, when it comes to moving averages,
simple moving averages,
we again put it into context of our 20- to
60-day time horizon.
We are three-month, 20- to 60-day long
short portfolio managers.
Therefore, our charts have to reflect the
time horizon that we're seeking to take
positions in.
We are trying to predict where the price
will be in one to three months' time
and we require momentum on our side.
So, when we're looking at 20- to 60-day
time horizons,
looking forward with simple moving
averages,
to understand the current momentum in the
market,
we have to understand the bigger picture
first
and look at longer-term charts of perhaps
two years or even a bit longer.
So, we do still, with price action, look
at the bigger picture
to put what we believe to be current
momentum into the context of our time
horizon.
So, typically, and there is no genuine
hard and fast rulebook here, guys,
but typically, we will start at two years
and then we will zoom in to a one-year
chart.
Then, we'll zoom in to perhaps the last
two quarters
and or the year-to-date chart.
And then, finally, we'll be looking at the
current quarter,
so the last three months.
So, when we're analyzing our simple moving
averages,
20-60, 120-250 days,
we get the bigger picture first,
then we zoom in to look for any
significant technical analysis patterns
and then we look for more shorter-term
price action momentum
and we just visually or optically compare
it to periods in the past.
So, for example, if we take a stock like
Wingstop,
so W-I-N-G, wing,
we can look at roughly a two-year period
using daily data for the price chart
and then calculate our 20, 60, 120, and
250-day simple moving averages.
And what we want to understand first
is with our 20- and 60-day SMAs,
what happens in terms of time horizon
when we get crossings of the 20-day SMA
crossing the 60-day SMA,
whether that's from above or below.
So, this will give us perspective moving
forward
for our 20- to 60-day time horizon.
So, if we look back to 2019, for example,
we will see that the 20-day simple moving
average for Wing
crosses the 60-day moving average from
above,
so bearish signal,
and this happens in September 2019.
And then if we look forward
to when it then crosses from below,
and we just count the number of months
that this took,
so it crosses from below in December 2019.
Now, of course, you can calculate
the exact amount of trading days that this
took,
but at this stage,
we're just looking at this visually,
optically,
to get an appreciation,
a rough estimate of how long this actually
takes.
So, roughly speaking, back in 2019,
from the moment that the 20-day crossed
the 60-day SMA,
from above to when it crossed from below,
we're looking at three months.
If we then fast forward into 2020,
the next time it crossed from above is in
March 2020.
This was obviously the violent sell-off
associated with the economic shutdown and
COVID-19.
And then the 20-day crosses the 60-day
from below.
If we fast forward again,
it crosses from below in April.
So, with that violent move down,
there was a quick and violent move up.
So, our time horizon there
was a period of around one month.
Next time the 20-day crosses the 60-day
from above
is in September 2020.
So, the time difference there is five
months.
And then from September,
the next time the 20-day crosses the
60-day moving average
from below,
we're looking at December 2020.
So, again, roughly speaking, three months.
Fast forward again
to find out when the 20-day SMA
crosses the 60-day from above.
We're looking at March 21.
And then fast forward again,
we see from below the 20-day cutting
the 60-day SMA from below.
We're looking at the end of April 2021.
So, a period of within two months.
So, about six weeks on this one.
And then just roughly four to five weeks
later.
So, the beginning of June 2021,
we're seeing the 20-day simple moving
average
approaching the 60-day,
but it hasn't quite got there yet or
crossed.
So, looking at the past performance
of what happens to the stock
when we get a 20-day crossing,
a 60-day from above,
it's reasonable to assume
that we'd be sitting around
and waiting for at least a couple of
months,
possibly three months,
for a turnaround in price momentum
to occur
to the positive
where it actually goes up.
And we can conclude
positive price momentum
from the 20-day crossing the 60-day from
below.
And then when we get periods
following a 20-day crossing a 60-day from
below,
we generally get conditions
of anything between one month
to five months
where the 20-day then crosses the 60-day
from above.
So, in 2019 and 2020,
we're looking at three to five-month
conditions
in that situation
and in more recent history.
So, the end of 2020,
beginning of 2021,
we're looking at a couple of months,
possibly three.
And just right in the immediate past,
if we do get a crossover here
where the 20-day crosses the 60-day from
above,
then under that condition,
the last time,
it crossed from below
to this current condition
was only around four to five weeks.
So, I guess it's safe to say,
other than the violent moves,
which were apparent around
the COVID sell-off
and then COVID rebound,
we're looking at periods here
of around a three-month wait
when price momentum
based on simple moving averages
turns negative
for it to then turn positive again
and a wait of around two months
for price momentum
based on simple moving averages
to turn negative again
once it's turned positive.
So, as mentioned,
we start at around two years
when we're looking at our SMAs.
We get an understanding
and appreciation
for price momentum
and the lengths of time
it takes in the past
for price momentum
to play out
based on SMAs.
And then we zoom in
to take a closer look.
So, here we have our one-year chart.
So, the past one year
we don't change anything else
except the start date
to look at the last year
and we keep all of our
simple moving averages
the same
and we just get a closer look.
So, imagine yourself
coming into this situation
with perhaps a fundamentally
bullish predisposition
and you're zooming in,
zooming down
to get more detail
on what could be
an advantageous entry point.
Well, in this situation
we just don't know
right now
whether the
20-day SMA
is going to cross
the 60-day SMA
from above
but the price momentum
does look
short-term
negative
versus the
medium-term.
If we look at the
green line
the medium-term
looks fairly benign
and
the 120-day
the longer-term
looks fairly benign
but the
one-year
the 250-day
is definitely
in an uptrend
as is
the stock
overall
when we look
at the bigger picture
of two years.
So, on a
20- to 60-day
time horizon
looking forward
if you were
fundamentally
bullish
in terms of
your fundamental
predisposition
coming into
this situation
you're probably
going to conclude
that this is
an amber
situation.
price momentum
could be better
could be displayed
better
in your favor
in the short-term
but in the medium-term
it's benign.
If you've done
your fundamental work
you've got genuine
catalysts in place
that you think
are going to occur
within the next
20- to 60 days
and price momentum
is going to shift
in your favor
because of fundamentals
then yes
you can have
a partial position
but short-term
price momentum
right now
we just don't know
if it's going to
cross the 60-day
from above
so the 20-day
crossing the 60-day
from above
so you would
probably get a bit
cheeky
on your entry points
on your entry price
so perhaps looking
to buy a partial
position
say one-third size
of your ideal
maximum size
or perhaps even
a half position
you could stick a bid
in to buy that
amount of shares
in the low
130s
you buy your
half position
and you sit back
and you wait to see
what the momentum
does
and also
if the catalysts
start coming through
and then you can
add to your position
on a price
momentum turn
or a fundamental
move
where the catalysts
are playing out
so again guys
no hard and fast
rules here
you saw how
we drilled down
from the two year
to the one year
and we just made
some sensible
deductions
and came to
a sensible
conclusion
these are just
best behavior
practices
they are not
rules
you're going to
have to obviously
interpret
every situation
individually
on its own
merits
now just as a
matter of illustration
for process
the next thing
you would do
is just look at
a year to date
if that's
significantly
different from
a one year chart
and
you would also
look at
overall
simple moving
averages
SMAs
are very useful
to us
as momentum
indicators
and they should
definitely be
on your price
action
or momentum
checklist
next up
is exponential
moving averages
or EMAs
and we look at
these two
as part of
our price action
momentum
checklist
and we treat
them very similarly
to simple
moving averages
but there is
obviously a
difference in
calculation here
between
exponential moving
averages
and simple
moving averages
so as with
a lot of
trading vernacular
especially in
technical analysis
and price
action indicators
the word
exponential
it sounds all
very cool
and exciting
but it really
isn't that
cool or exciting
so if you think
back to our
very simple
formula
for simple
moving averages
you'll recall
our chosen
time horizon
20 days
the 20 day
SMA
is just
simply
the sum
of the closing
prices
for the past
20 days
divided
by 20 days
however
if you think
about how
this is
calculated
when we're
calculating it
we are
sitting on
day 21
so the first
day of a
20 day
simple moving
average
is day 21
and that
covers the
previous
20 days
and when we're
calculating
the 20 day
moving average
it's on a
rolling basis
so there's
a lag
effect
of 20
days
an exponential
moving average
reduces
this lag
by applying
more weight
to recent
prices
and we have
a weighting
that's applied
to the most
recent prices
and this
depends
on the number
of periods
in the moving
average itself
so exponential
moving averages
differ from
simple moving
averages
in that
a given
day's
EMA
calculation
depends
on the
EMA's
calculations
for all
the days
prior
to that
day
now
similar
to
SMA's
for
significant
EMA's
we use
the same
time periods
as with
SMA's
so we're
using
and 250
days
for
exponential
moving
averages
and we
of course
apply our
time frame
for long
short
portfolio
managers
of 20
to 60
days
so the
formula
or calculation
for exponential
moving averages
obviously differs
from simple
moving averages
the exponential
moving average
for today
is the
closing price
of yesterday
multiplied by
the multiplier
plus the
exponential moving
average calculation
of yesterday
multiplied by
1 minus the
multiplier
and the multiplier
itself is the
number 2
divided by the
number of
observations in the
data plus 1
okay so let's
run through an
example here
so let's do a
20 day EMA
so for a
the multiplier
will be calculated
as 2
over 21
so 20
plus 1
and that is
equal to
spot
so our
multiplier
is 0
spot
0.0952381 for a 20-day exponential moving
average. So let's say a stock closed
yesterday
at $65.89 and had a 20-day SMA of 62.54.
And to get our first EMA data point, we
take the 20-day
SMA and multiply that by 1 minus the
multiplier, 0.0952381. And this results in
an EMA today of $62.80.
Now, if on that day, the stock then closed
at $67.22, we would then use this closing
price
and the previous day's EMA of the $62.86
to calculate the next day's or the current
day's EMA.
So we take $67.22, multiply that through
by the multiplier, and then we add the
previous day's
EMA, $62.86, multiply through by 1 minus
the multiplier, and then add those results
together.
That gives us a new day EMA of $63.27. And
then to continue working out subsequent
days of the
exponential moving average, we keep using
yesterday's closing price and yesterday's
EMA to calculate
the current day's EMA subsequently moving
forward. Now, we do have a download in the
download area
to this video where we actually have
simple moving averages versus exponential
moving averages.
So the file name there is SMA underscore
versus underscore EMA. And if you look
through the
spreadsheet there, look through the
formulas, this will give you a better
understanding of
the difference between the two. So in the
example, in the spreadsheet, we've shown a
10-day exponential
moving average with 30-day periods. In
reality, when you're looking at obviously
much bigger
stock price charts and data sets, there's
going to be a lot more days. But the
spreadsheet you can use
as a template to further your
understanding of the differences between
SMA and EMA. And you can also
use past stock price data over even much
longer periods to work out SMA and EMA
yourself. And even compare
those results when you're looking at a
particular stock. And this is all very
helpful stuff to help you better
understand it in the first place. But when
you're actually pulling up
charts and looking at SMAs versus EMAs,
when you've done the fundamental
groundwork of how the calculations
actually work, you better understand the
visualization of the chart.
So unlike most retail traders who pull up
moving averages for simple moving averages
and exponential
moving averages and they don't really
understand the calculations on what's
going on, you will have a far better
understanding of what's actually going on
behind the picture or visuals on the
screen.
Now just for reference, a 20-day
exponential moving average can also be
referred to as the 9.52% EMA.
So that's our multiplier, the 0.0952. And
the 10-day exponential moving average can
be referred to as the 18.18% EMA.
Multiplier for the 10-day exponential
moving average is 0.1818.
So for our time period as long-short
portfolio managers over 20, 60 days, we
are using 20, 60, 120, and 250-day EMAs.
So for 20 days, we have what's termed as a
9.52% EMA, for 60 days, a 3.27% EMA, for
120 days, a 1.65% EMA, and 250 days, a
0.79% EMA.
Now, before we look at examples on a chart
of exponential moving averages, we're
actually going to look at our fourth
momentum indicator,
which is moving average convergence
divergence.
And this is because the MACD, the moving
average convergence divergence
calculation, draws on the exponential
moving average data.
So the MACD indicator is what's termed as
a momentum oscillator that measures the
difference in two EMA periods.
So the MACD is calculated by subtracting
the longer-term EMA from the shorter-term
EMA.
And this creates what's called the MACD
line.
And the MACD line fluctuates above and
below a 0 line as the EMAs converge,
cross, and diverge from each other.
On top of having the MACD line and the 0
line, there's also a third line called the
signal line that's created by taking an
EMA of the MACD itself.
So the formula that you're always going to
bump into, the default formula for MACD
that will typically be the default on
websites and in any software that you
download for technical analysis and price
action,
the default formula for MACD is the
12-period EMA minus the 26-period EMA.
So this gives the MACD line, and then a
nine-day EMA of the MACD line itself is
worked out as the signal line.
So using a 12- and 26-day EMA is the most
commonly distributed method of
calculation, and pretty much all retail
traders use this method and follow it
almost like a religion.
But again, as with so many things in
technical analysis and price action
indicators, no one ever seems to ask what
the significance is of 12, 26, and nine
days.
The only remote or close to significance
would be in the Forex markets, where one
week is six days, two weeks is 12 days,
and nine days is randomly one and a half
weeks.
But then again, that kind of leaves us
hanging dry when we try to explain what
these numbers mean in terms of their
significance, because it just leaves us
asking, why 26 days?
What's the significance there?
So even in the Forex markets, there's a
bit of randomness there.
These numbers don't really mean much,
especially nine and 26 days.
But in the stock market, we can say with a
very high level of confidence that there's
no significance.
They basically mean nothing.
So for us, as longshore portfolio managers
in the stock market, for stocks, these
periods just have no significance.
So for us, our 20, 60, 120, and 250-day
exponential moving averages must be used
to calculate the MACD line and the signal
line we calculate as 10 days, so two
trading weeks.
So our modified MACD has the following
formula.
MACD is equal to 20-day EMA minus the
60-day EMA with a 10-day EMA of the MACD
as the signal line.
So now we understand how our EMAs and MACD
is calculated properly for us as longshore
portfolio managers in the stock market.
We can have a look at an example here.
So here we have a roughly 18-month chart
of the stock Chewy CHWY.
So we have our daily price data, our open
high low close data for daily, and we have
our exponential moving averages calculated
here.
So we have our 20-day EMA, our 60-day EMA,
our 120-day EMA, and our 250-day EMA.
And at the bottom of our chart, underneath
the price chart, you can see the formulas
for MACD and the signal line.
And there's also another calculation
difference between the MACD and the signal
line.
So the white line is our MACD, that's the
20-day EMA minus the 60-day EMA, currently
at minus 4.9868.
So a negative value for the MACD line
simply means that the 20-day exponential
moving average must be below the 60-day
exponential moving average.
And if you look back, for example, to the
last time the 20-day EMA crossed the
60-day EMA from above, which you can see
on the chart is in March 2021.
This is where the 20-day and 60-day MACD
line crossed the zero line from above.
So all pretty straightforward stuff, but
in terms of vernacular, if the 20-day EMA
is greater or above the 60-day EMA, we
have what is called a positive MACD line.
And if the 20-day EMA is less than or
below the 60-day EMA, we have what is
called a negative MACD line.
So in this instance, right now with Chewy,
we have a negative for the MACD line.
Now, what we also have is our 10-day
signal line, which, remember, is an
exponential moving average of the MACD
line itself.
And what we can do is, as with anything,
is zoom in to take a closer look.
So if we chart both the MACD line and the
signal line, so we have the MACD line of
the 20- and 60-day periods,
and we have the signal line for 10-day EMA
of the MACD line, which is in red, we can
visually see when the MACD line crosses
the signal line from above and below.
And we can also calculate and chart the
differences between the two.
And the difference between the two is
actually charted, if we zoom in further,
at the zero line.
So if you recall, the zero line is simply
on the occasion when the 20-day EMA minus
the 60-day EMA is equal to zero, so it's
when they're crossing.
But the difference between the MACD line
and the signal line is also charted across
the zero line.
But you have to remember, it's a different
calculation.
So don't get confused thinking when you're
looking at these green bars that the green
bars represent the difference between the
20-day EMA and the 60-day EMA, because
they don't.
The green bars, the difference is the
difference in value between the MACD line
and the signal line.
But it's charted across the zero line.
So now you know how it's calculated and
how it works.
I guess the big question here is how do we
interpret all of this?
Well, we have a 10-point checklist here
for EMAs and MACD as to what it means for
your timing appraisal as part of the
overall trade idea generation process.
So the first two we've actually covered
when we were looking visually at the MACD
line.
If the 20-day EMA is greater than the
60-day EMA, we have a positive MACD line
in absolute terms.
If the 20-day EMA is less than the 60-day
EMA, we have a negative MACD line in
absolute terms.
Now, when it comes to the MACD line
relative to the signal line, if the
difference between the 20-day EMA and the
60-day EMA is greater than the 10-day
signal line, we have what is called
positive divergence.
So we've got two measures here in how we
interpret things.
We have the absolute measure and the
relative measure.
Now, when it comes to the relative
measure, if the MACD line is moving
further away from the signal line
positively, it means that there's positive
price divergence and momentum.
And in the opposite, if the MACD line is
moving further away from the signal line
negatively, it means that there's negative
price divergence and momentum.
And when momentum is starting to fade, if
the MACD line is moving closer to the
signal line from the positive, it means
that there's convergence and slowing
positive momentum.
And if the MACD line is moving closer to
the signal line from the negative, it
means there's convergence and slowing
negative momentum.
And on the relative measure, when the MACD
line actually converges, so when the MACD
line crosses the signal line from above,
there's actually been confirmed
convergence and there's what's called
negative price momentum.
So when you're using this checklist for
your timing appraisal, when it comes to
EMAs and MACDs, the most common price
action indicator that you're going to be
using for the MACD is actually the signal
line crossover from above.
And below.
Because this is when convergence is
actually confirmed.
So we have confirmed positive and negative
price action.
And the next thing you're going to
consider is the MACD line itself in
absolute terms and whether that's positive
or negative and where it is in relation to
the zero line crossover.
Now, if we go back one slide and we just
look again at the MACD and signal line for
Chewy, how would you actually interpret
this?
Well, we have a negative MACD line, as we
know, the signal line is also negative.
So when we're interpreting this in
absolute terms, the MACD line being
negative means there's negative price
action overall in the bigger picture.
But on a relative basis, when we compare
the MACD line to the signal line, we've
just recently had a crossover of the
signal line from below.
So if we think of this in the context of
our fundamental predisposition, and we
think of this as a bullish fundamental
predisposition, and we're pulling up the
EMAs and the MACD.
If we go back a further slide and we look
at the short-term exponential moving
average, which is our 20 days EMA, is
currently bouncing along or bouncing off
the long-term EMA, our 250-day one-year
exponential moving average.
And, of course, we can see that the 20-day
EMA crossed the 60-day EMA from above back
in March.
So overall, negative price action on
larger timeframes.
So for a medium-term timeframe, negative
price action.
But on a shorter timeframe, we are
starting to see less negative momentum and
signs of actually positive price action.
So although there's not overall positive
price action in the name, what we are
seeing is less negative price action and
support coming in for the stock around
these levels.
So we have some signs of positive price
action and some signs of positive price
momentum or price action.
So in terms of our interpretation here, if
we go back to our 10-point checklist, we
can figure out what's going on here.
We have our number two condition, which is
the 20-day EMA being less than the 60-day
EMA.
So we have a negative MACD line.
We have a positive difference.
So that's our number three condition.
The difference between the 20-day EMA and
the 60-day EMA is greater than the signal
line, the 10-day signal line.
So we have positive divergence.
We also have the MACD line moving on the
signal line positively.
So this means that there's positive price
divergence again.
So there is momentum.
So this is our number five condition.
And in the recent past, we've also had the
MACD line crossing the signal line from
below.
So there's been convergence.
So again, positive price momentum.
So on a relative basis, the MACD line
versus the signal line, we are seeing
positive price action here.
But from a technical standpoint, from a
price action standpoint, in the bigger
picture, the stock is certainly not out of
the woods here.
Because for the MACD line, we still have
in absolute terms a negative.
So if you were coming into this with a
fundamental predisposition of bullish,
what do you think you'd actually be doing
here?
Well, it's certainly not a red light.
It's also not a full position size green
light.
It's most probably a partial position, an
amber signal.
You can use your discretion, buy some
stock, and perhaps sit back for a few
weeks and reassess in a few weeks' time.
Whether you add to the position or not.
Where would you add to the position?
Well, you would probably add to the
position if the MACD line went positive.
So do use this checklist moving forward.
It's very useful for just interpreting
things and getting used to the
interpretation of EMAs and MACD.
Now, as always, when it comes to this
stuff, we're more interested in getting
the big things right.
Shorter-term traders will use shorter-term
MACD and signal lines and go into a lot of
depth
and compare the price action of a chart.
So the price chart to the MACD for what we
call divergence signals.
We, as longshore portfolio managers in the
20- to 60-day time horizon, we don't need
to go that deep.
Why?
Because we're not generating trade ideas
based on price.
And our time horizon does allow us to be
wrong for at least a week or two or maybe
even a month.
All we need to do is get the big things
right.
So you really don't need to go too far
with this and go down rabbit holes and
become a victim of the laws of diminishing
marginal utility
in terms of the work you put in to your
timing process.
All we need with technical analysis and
price action is the basics and a good
understanding of our indicators
to time our entry into positions and our
exits out of positions better than if we
weren't using it.
Now, one thing you have to understand
about the MACD is that it doesn't provide
parameters for either overbought and
oversold conditions.
Although visually, we can look at the MACD
in the past and pinpoint where stocks were
open quotes overbought and open quote
oversold
and in those conditions, the MACD doesn't
have any upper or lower limits or
parameters to constrain its movement.
For example, in very sharp rallies and
sell-offs in a stock, the MACD can just
continue getting bigger and smaller.
So let's say in a bad situation for a
stock where a stock fundamentally warns on
their forward-looking EPS outlook
and there's wholesale selling of the stock
for literally months.
If you, as a trader, are staring at the
MACD thinking that the negative divergence
of the MACD from the signal line
simply can't continue because it's at
historically wide levels, then you need to
think again because it literally can.
And the same goes in the opposite for a
company that's aggressively increasing
their forward-looking EPS estimates
and there's wholesale accumulation of the
stock from, say, pension funds for months
on end.
You just shouldn't be staring at the
historically wide positive divergence of
the MACD line from the signal line
and thinking that it's a shorting
opportunity.
Because most retail traders don't really
bother to do the work on the calculations
of their price action indicators
and really understand them, this is why
retail traders that get their trade ideas
only from TA
and price action patterns and indicators
eventually always get run over.
So they get run over by big fundamental
moves and a lack of understanding of both
the fundamentals themselves
and the very technical analysis and price
action indicators that they espouse.
So just understand, guys, how EMA and MACD
properly works
and understand the calculations and the
interpretations properly.
Now, we're going to move on to our final
momentum indicator.
We're going to be looking at Heiken Ashi
candlestick charts.
So all of the charts that we've looked at
up to this point and that we've used as
examples have used regular candlesticks.
So we've been using predominantly daily,
open, high, low and close data.
And you'll recall on the charts we've been
using, we've had hollow candles for days
when the stock has a closing price above
its opening price
However, with the study of price action
and momentum in prices, we can introduce
you here to a new kind of candlestick
chart called the Heiken Ashi.
And with the Heiken Ashi, the candles are
worked out differently.
So if we just look at a chart here of the
S&P 500 cash index, this is a chart where
we're using regular.
And you can see visually when we look at a
Heiken Ashi that the candles visually look
different.
And that's because the candles are worked
out differently.
So the parameters for a Heiken Ashi candle
versus a regular candle differ because the
calculation for the parameters, the values
for open, high, low and close are
different.
So let's break this down and look at the
calculation and interpret this properly.
So the phrase Heiken Ashi in Japanese, it
simply means average bar.
So it all sounds very sophisticated and
very fancy.
And technical analysis guys, they do like
to use a lot of Japanese words to make
them sound somehow scientific or
mathematically gifted.
Implying that they have some sort of edge
versus the great unwashed retail trader,
unknowledgeable guy in financial markets.
But as with most things in technical
analysis and price action indicators, it
sounds a lot more sophisticated than it
actually is.
If they just use the words, if they just
use the words, for example, average bar in
English instead of Heiken Ashi in
Japanese, you would likely be much less
impressed.
So when you encounter these names in
technical analysis, just translate it back
into English and make it so that in your
vocabulary,
you're using the English phrase as much as
the Japanese phrase and perhaps even get
used to just using the English phrase all
the time.
So this way you'll be able to concentrate
on the calculation and what exactly the
technical analysis or price action
indicator is.
If it's a fancy name and then forgetting
what the TA or price action indicator is
actually calculating.
So in the case of Heiken Ashi or the
average bar, what are we actually
calculating here?
Instead of using the straightforward
candlestick data for open, high, low,
close to form a candle, the average bar
uses another formula.
So the open data of a candle is calculated
as 0.5 of the sum of the open of the
previous bar plus the close of the
previous bar.
The high data for a candle is the maximum
value from the high, open or close.
And the low value for the data is taken as
the minimum value from the same data
that's sourced for the high data.
So the minimum value taken from the low,
open or close.
And then the close data is taken as 0.25
of the sum of the open plus the high plus
the low plus the close.
So you can see here where the OHLC data
for average bars or Heiken Ashi differs
versus regular candles.
So the high and low data is not simply the
high or low for that asset in that time
period.
Whether we're looking at hourly, daily,
weekly or monthly candles.
The high and low data is taken as the
maximum for the high of the high, open and
close data.
And the low is taken as the minimum.
So the lowest point of the low, open and
close.
Then when it comes to the open and close
data, they are both worked out as
averages.
So the open data of the next candle is
just the open of the previous bar plus the
close of the previous bar divided by two.
Then the close of the current bar is the
open of the current bar plus the high, low
and close of the current bar divided by
four.
So both the open and close data that is
sourced is then averaged.
But you can see that the open of a new
candle, the data that's being sourced and
averaged is data from the previous candle.
So what the average bar or Heiken Ashi
achieves is a smoother result for the
candles.
Because all previous days that are
referenced are average bars too.
Now, also remember that the average bars
stay hollow during a predominant uptrend
and they're filled in during a predominant
downtrend.
And when we analyze average bars in terms
of price action, it tells us what the
dominant trend is, whereas the normal OHLC
representation displays or shows us a
variation in the candles within a
predominant uptrend or downtrend.
So the Heiken Ashi average bar analysis is
very useful to us in terms of helping us
with our timing for entry and exits.
In the context of the 20 to 60 day time
horizon, it's useful to start by looking
at weekly data.
So we can see here with an example of
XPEL, imagine you are coming into this
stock with a fundamental predisposition of
bullish in March 2021.
So if you look at the weekly candle on the
chart at the beginning of March 2021, you
can see that there's a big variation there
in the data.
The range of the range of the candle, the
high and the low is $60 for the high.
And by just visualizing here, it's
probably around $45 for the low.
But what you would notice in the history
of this stock price using average bars is
that when we use weekly data here, we can
see that there's only periods of one, two
or three weeks with the exception of
February and March 2020.
There's only periods of one, two or three
weeks where there's a predominant
downtrend.
So this can certainly help us with our
timing if we're coming into this stock
with a fundamental predisposition of
bullish.
So if we can accumulate in the second or
fourth downtrend, the odds based on
historical analysis of average bars are
probably in our favor.
And then we can move on to the daily data
for XPEL and we can take a look at what
happens in these periods of predominant
downtrend that only seem to last for one,
two or three weeks.
So if we're sitting around the beginning
of March around that time and we look at
previous daily data where we have
predominant downtrends, the downtrends
seem to last only a week or two and we
have moves down of around $10 a share.
So if you were coming into this stock with
a fundamental predisposition of bullish
around the beginning or middle of March,
what would you be doing?
You'd probably be holding out for
purchases of stock, certainly in the low
50s, if not at $50.
And if you've got a strong fundamental
view based on solid fundamental analysis
and it's backed up in the technicals and
price action of the stock, you'd feel
fairly comfortable about accumulating
stock here in the low 50s.
Then as the trade develops and turns into
a winning position, we get our positive
price action, so a positive upward trend
of the average bars into April, reaching
the mid 60s by the beginning of May.
And then we have a downtrend, which could
actually present an opportunity for us to
pick spots and add to this winning trade.
And if we look back at the weekly data and
we look at the areas on the chart where we
have a predominantly positive uptrend in
the average bars, the average bars tend to
last between five and 10 weeks.
So this type of understanding of the data
and the trends in terms of time horizon
can actually help us with our exit.
And in all probability, we'd be looking to
probably exit the position around week 10.
So it wouldn't be too much of a stretch to
say that given the predominant uptrend and
our time horizon of 20 to 60 days,
we probably would have exited this trade
based on our fundamental analysis, our
catalysts, our timing,
somewhere in the high $70 to $80 range
after getting in in the low 50s.
Now, of course, there's multiple other
examples of average bars, Haiken Ashi
analysis.
Again, with this stock, Teneco, we're
using weekly data first, understanding
what happens during predominant uptrends
and downtrends and adjusting our timing
appraisal accordingly.
We then move to daily data, and that helps
us pinpoint better entries and exits.
Even when we're looking on the short side,
not just on the long side, Haiken Ashi
average bars obviously can help us as well
for short entries.
So here we have TAN, the solar ETF in the
United States, and if we're coming into
this situation with a fundamental
predisposition of short,
this is obviously at a sector level, and
we would probably much rather be short one
of the biggest holdings of the ETF.
But we can see at the sector level, the
average bar analysis can help us on short
entries,
not just for the sector, but also for
holdings within that ETF.
So for single stocks in the ETF, look at
getting really accurate by looking at the
daily data in the bigger picture,
and then zooming in into the much shorter
term picture.
And what we're trying to do here is
pinpoint shorts when positive predominant
trends in the average bars have been
exhausted,
and they're turning into predominant
negative trends.
And then we're probably looking to cover
shorts when we have predominant negative
trends that are becoming exhausted,
and they're turning into short-term
positive Haiken Ashi or average bar
trends.
And if you think back to our fundamental
analysis when we were looking at shorts,
and think back and remember our short
waves of phase one, phase two, phase
three, phase four, and phase five,
Haiken Ashi average bars can really help
us with our timing in terms of phases for
shorts.
So another example on the short side here,
Beyond Meat, BYND, where we can analyze
the daily average bars,
daily Haiken Ashi, and understand what
happens from a timing perspective when we
get reversals into the positive trends
And how long they last, and we can pick
our spots, obviously murried up with the
fundamental analysis.
We can pick our spots and enter short
positions at better times.
If we look at another example here, with
Uber, imagine yourself coming into a
situation here in May, middle of May 2021,
with a fundamental predisposition of
bearish.
You see the stock breaking a significant
support level.
Then the predominant negative trend
becomes exhausted, around $45, turning
into a positive trend.
But you know from past data that the
positive trend is probably only going to
last around 10 trading days
before turning back into a predominantly
negative trend.
You will be holding off, hanging back, and
waiting to get better prices on your
short, probably around $50.
And then perhaps adding to the short on a
break to the downside.
Average bars can also help us with ranging
stocks as well.
So here on the screen we have ALK, Alaska
Airlines.
If we were coming into this stock with
perhaps a fundamental bearish
predisposition,
post the COVID-19 recovery rally.
And then we see the stock ranging on the
average bar analysis, Heiken Ashi.
We can obviously zoom in and attempt to
pinpoint our entry prices.
And we're probably looking to get
something on on the short side,
given our fundamental predisposition and
our timing appraisal of the average bars.
We're probably looking to get something on
around $70, or if we can, a little bit
higher.
And then add to it on a break to the
downside.
So use the average bar analysis.
Obviously, there's multiple examples out
there in the market.
Go and look at them yourself and start
trying to figure out predominant uptrends
and downtrends
and how long they actually last.
So when they get exhausted and when
there's turning points in the overall
predominant trend to the upside or
downside.
So for price action analysis, the Heiken
Ashi candlestick charts help us to
identify dominant trends.
So it basically acts as a price action
head check for us versus regular
candlestick charts,
where we might actually get some false
signals when we're considering both entry
and exits.
Use the Heiken Ashi average bar analysis
in conjunction with the other price action
and momentum indicators
mentioned in this video, like the RSI,
simple moving averages, exponential moving
averages, and MACD.
Use it in conjunction with them to get an
overall picture of price momentum.
Now, let's tie all of this up together for
our timing appraisal with both technical
analysis and price action.
Remember from the previous video when we
discussed technical analysis and incorrect
timing?
Well, when we're using technical analysis
and price action indicators in conjunction
with each other,
the same mindset applies.
We are 20 to 60-day, predominantly
fundamental, long-short portfolio
managers.
We use both technical analysis and price
action indicators for timing only.
In your overall trade idea generation
process, if you get to the TA and PA stage
and think the timing is wrong,
that's totally fine.
Just sit back and wait.
Stick it on the watch list and just wait
for a better entry.
And if you're already in a position and
the technical analysis and price action
indicators,
keep confirming that your fundamental view
is correct, and it's a winner, it's a
winning position.
You're probably going to let the position
run.
And if you're already in a position, and
both the technicals and the price action
indicators keep denying your fundamental
view,
and you've got a losing position, you're
probably going to do best to cut the
position.
Now, you have to remember that when we're
using both technical analysis and price
action indicators,
we don't require perfect timing.
If you've got a strong fundamental view,
and it's backed up by solid fundamental
analysis and catalysts,
and the TA and the PA indicators are lined
up pretty well,
it doesn't have to be perfect.
It's probably a green light.
Remember, at the end of the day, we are
traders, and we're trying to predict the
future,
and we're not reacting to current price.
We're trying to predict that in the next
20 to 60 days, things will go in our
favor.
However, we are not stubborn beings.
Stocks will do whatever they want to do,
and we can't influence the price.
So, we don't fight the technical analysis
and the price action of a stock,
and we certainly don't engage in stubborn
behavior.
We always try to seek to get a position on
within 20 days, but if it's not right to
do so,
obviously, we do not fight it.
Now, when it comes to timing, we can, of
course, become more agnostic about timing
our positions.
This is preventative risk management in
itself.
So, how do we do this?
Well, we can scale into longs and shorts,
and this is referring to taking partial
positions before we put on full positions,
and we use technical analysis and price
action in this way to make our executions
better and more optimal.
Therefore, we are, by default, engaging in
preventative risk management.
However, in a well-diversified long-short
portfolio, this obviously requires trading
accounts that are larger.
And, by the way, scaling not just into
longs and shorts, but also out of
positions, applies here as well.
However, we can use technical analysis and
price action indicators to help us scale
out of longs and shorts for our exits.
Now, of course, we do have choices here.
We can also totally forget altogether
about TA and PA and just put trades on
immediately, not caring about it at all.
However, we definitely would not recommend
this.
Because we are long-short portfolio
managers within the 20- to 60-day time
horizon, our timing is important.
We are trading the stock price around
catalysts within that time horizon.
So, we are not investors.
We're trading in the 20- to 60-day time
horizon, and our timing really does
matter.
From what we've looked at in the last few
videos, when it comes to TA and PA, you
can obviously see from the examples that
we've been through, you can add a lot of
value with your timing.
However, we can become more agnostic where
our timing becomes less important, i.e.,
trying to buy at or near the lows and
trying to sell at or near highs.
And this comes with a change in trade
structure.
So, we can utilize options structures to
become more agnostic in our timing.
And there are multiple options structures
that allow you to become more agnostic
with your timing and therefore place less
importance on technical analysis and price
action indicators.
However, this is well beyond the scope of
this video series, the PTM video series,
and it can only really be covered in
mentoring programs where you're trading
with real money under the supervision of
an ITPM professional trading mentor.
But if you're comfortable with long, short
stock portfolios, and you're going to be
engaging in technical analysis and price
action appraisal in terms of timing, just
remember TA and PA are not exact sciences.
Like the discipline of trading overall,
they are artistic sciences, and used
correctly, they can definitely add value
over many trades over a long period of
time as part of your overall trade idea
generation process.
Just don't use TA and PA to generate trade
idea.
That, ladies and gentlemen, is a game for
fools.
Okay, so that brings us to the end.
of our timing section of the PTM video
series, let's hop in to the next video and
go to the desk for a recap and a rundown.